Well,
what happens in the stock market?
Bubbles.
It's too much enthusiasm.
People see an unspecified,
a reward of unspecified magnitude.
So it's like a magic treasure.
That's what happened with the Internet.
The Internet is a magic treasure.
True,
true.
Look at Google,
they got all the treasure.
Everyone knew it was there,
thought they knew.
No one knew where it was.
So they're chasing it like Matt,
right?
Even an enthusiastic rash.
Was it stupid
for lots of people?
Wasn't stupid for the people
who happen to be in Google.
Okay,
so enthusiasm can easily
get out of control.
That's what happens when the
party gets out of control.
That's what happens.
Enthusiasm makes people impulsive.
It makes them discount the
future because today is so great.
Enthusiasm turns into mania.
And so you know,
everybody says,
well,
you should be happy.
You should be telling
positive effect all the time.
So no wrong pause.
Dab aspect is dangerous.
You're always telling your
kids to stop being so happy.
You don't notice it,
but they're running
around causing trouble.
They're having a wild time.
They're throwing their arms in the air
and they're laughing and they're running
around,
they're having fun.
You say,
Hey,
quiet down,
and if you count your
disciplinary actions,
you'd be shocked at how often what you're
doing is telling your children to stop
having so much fun.
Okay.